crowd control
what do the books say about this one now
I think we've lost it all
there's nothing to explain the distance
[Music]
floating away
in the way
[Music]
100 Days with no reply now I think I've
lost my mind
there's nothing keeping me from going
outside
times
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel it away
[Music]
[Applause]
if you start floating away
[Music]
foreign
I hope you enjoyed this video uh a
friend took me past that Park several
weeks ago and the first thought I had in
my head was I need to shoot a video
there so so big thanks to that friend
Jordan Harvey and big thanks to ultra
POI for sponsoring this video and giving
me an excuse to get out and explore my
flow in town if you'd like to grab a set
of these or POI LED contact POI that I
was using in this video you can do so by
heading on over to ultrapoi.com and
using the promo code drexfactor with a
zero instead of an O at checkout that
gets you a discount on your order and it
helps out the channel so everybody wins
thanks once again to ultra POI for
making this video possible and speaking
of thank yous I have to thank the
friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping me make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel That is Lane machinski
thank you both so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission also this video would not be
possible were not for the kind support
of all of these lovely people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very very generous support if you out
there watching are not currently
supporter and you'd like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world go check that out please and
thank you now if you'd like to check out
some of my other flow videos I will
include a link to a playlist of them
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
things that you might like this top
video based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look as well
thanks so much for watching have
yourselves a good one make sure to get
outside to flow today and I'll be back
with a new video for you on Friday
peace